all right so as he mentioned my name's
elissa batula I've been working with
machine learning for about seven years
and I'm going to talk to you about what
are your first steps if you want to get
started in machine learning whether
that's for a personal project or your
boss has this great idea our project
could be better if we use machine
learning you're on that team so a good
first step is what is machine learning
and how is it different from what I was
doing before so I like this definition
of machine learning there's a million of
them
but it's the science of you're getting
computers to act without being
explicitly programmed so in traditional
programming you're telling the computer
what to do line by line with machine
learning we're teaching it to make
decisions or take actions without
programming each of those individual
steps or telling it in this particular
scenario you need to do this thing
and so we do this by showing it lots of
examples so it's kind of like whenever
you're learning a new thing especially
like as a kid when you learn to tie your
shoes someone show you how it's done
you try they tell you what you did wrong
you try again
and so a kind of metaphor exercise
that's often used with new programmers
is how do you teach a computer to make a
sandwich so the idea is the the
instructor is trying to teach people
that the computer is only going to do
what you tell it and nothing more so if
you've never done this before the
students will try and write down what
steps are involved in making a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich and teacher
will act them out and try and make it
entertaining for the students when they
realize they missed a step or two so if
you forget to say you know take the
peanut butter and jelly out of the jars
just put it between the bread you might
get something like this two loaves of
bread with some jars in between them or
okay so you tell them to get the peanut
butter out of the jar
and you forget to tell them to open the
lid
you might start stabbing it with a knife
because they didn't tell you you had to
open the jar and so this can get kind of
entertaining but it's also kind of
our machine learning comes in so when
you don't with this exercise like you've
you taught the students about being
explicit with the computer but you still
haven't taught the computer to make it
peanut butter and jelly sandwich there's
a million if statements what if the
knife is rotated a quarter of a degree
differently than when you learn to pick
it up what if the bread is in a
different drawer because your sibling
doesn't know where it belongs like how
do you teach a computer to deal with
this and so with machine learning it's
not actually a metaphor there are people
teaching robots to make I'm not sure
about sandwiches but definitely pancakes
and other foods and so this is where
that teaching by example instead of line
by line every single if statement comes
in so back to our problem you are the
developer and you've been told we're
doing machine learning now where do you
start so the first step is not to start
writing code and it's also not to start
memorizing a bunch of algebra problems
your first step is actually to change
your mindset so you're not putting
building blocks together to make
something work like if you're making a
website there are tools out there that
are pretty well known you just need to
pick the best ones for your
circumstances and make them work and
behave together so you're doing more of
gathering data and experimenting with
different things to see if they work and
this can be a hard change especially for
project managers and people who want
specific timelines like I can build a
website next amount of time but saying
yeah sure I'll have this machine
learning program working in a month it's
hard to say it could work on your first
try and be done really quickly or it
could take a year to figure out how to
get it working so this is getting better
as there's more off-the-shelf things of
it available like people have solved
some general problems like getting text
off of document there are some things
Amazon has one Google has one where you
can can take an image and pull the text
off of it so there's some things that
you can just use off-the-shelf but if
you're building anything on your own
it's much harder to predict a timeline
and so getting people to understand that
can be a tough part
so some things to keep in mind there's
much more managing of data organizing
your data double-checking that it's
correct all of that stuff finding the
data in the first place you might
realize you don't have enough data to do
a machine learning problem and so now
you're a programmer and instead of
writing code you're looking for sources
of data I mention a little bit about all
of the unknowns so there's a lot of
unknowns you're running experiments to
see what works just a lot more time
experimenting and seeing will this work
won't it work rather than saying yeah
I'm gonna write that this week you also
need new ways to determine if what
you're doing works so there's new
definitions for something that's good
so usually you you write some code and
you test if I push button a dis action B
happen or does the system crash and
there's still some of that because it's
still a program running the code but you
need to also make sure you algorithm
works on the whole and this can be a
problem with some people if you want to
determine the difference there's a cat
and a dog and you give it a picture of a
dog and it says a picture of a cat you
don't actually know that your system is
broken because you've only tested on one
example what if that is the only picture
of a dog that gets wrong you have to
test on a lot of different examples and
look at the overall picture but usually
it gets it right or rarely gets it right
and so it's a different way of
determining whether or not something's
working well so we talked about changing
your mindset the second step is still
not code it's actually determining if
machine learning even makes sense for
what you're trying to do so some
problems will work well with machine
learning they're a great fit solve some
great problems sometimes the solution is
actually better done with just
traditional programming maybe some
clever if statements and also just be
careful if someone's asking you do weird
computer magic like just because machine
learning is a thing Computers still
aren't magic I wish but not yet so what
is good machine learning good at
it's good for things where you have lots
of data to train on so I've said a
couple times I'll probably repeat myself
many more times but you're teaching it
from examples so you need a lot of
examples to share the computer when you
see you know this situation I want you
to do why when you see this other
situation I want you to do Z or if
there's too many edge cases or it's too
complicated to describe with a set of
rules or math so the peanut butter and
jelly sandwich is an example of this
there's too many rules for how to pick
up a knife and how to hold the knife and
get the peanut butter out of the jar
that it wouldn't be a good fit for
traditional programming and initiative
having the data it has to be informative
so there has to be some kind of pattern
in the data you don't necessarily have
to be able to see it as a human but
there has to be some pattern that
relates what the computer sees to what
it does conversely if you don't have a
lot of data you either need to get the
data or machine learning is probably not
the solution you want to go for or if
there if something can be described
simply like a couple if statements or
rules there's there's no reason to go
reinvent the wheel machine learning is
great but if you can do it in a simpler
way you should do it that way or if your
data can't teach it how to solve the
problem it's also not going to work so a
little more specific
I mentioned identifying cats versus dogs
so image identification general machine
learning is really really good at
there's competitions for it's awesome
and also humans are really good at this
you can look at a picture and quickly
decide yeah that's a cat or a dog but
how would you describe what you're doing
like it's the shape of ears you know is
it the length of the dog's nose but then
what about a bulldog that's got kind of
a stubby nose like a cat but computers
are really good at this about it a bad
use case would be solving a math problem
you look at this and I don't know what
the answer is well I know because I
wrote it down it's about 42 but like you
look at this and you have no idea what
this is I have no desire to solve it
myself but computers are really good at
this we have these tools they can solve
math
there's no reason to go out and like
fine machine learning to teach you to do
math Computers already very good at math
it's an oversimplified guideline that
I've heard and I really like is that if
a human can assign a label or a value to
something in less than a second it could
be a good candidate for machine learning
so something's like a quick gut decision
that you just kind of know it you know
it's sex it's a dog or it's a cat so if
you're ready for you know a change in
mindset yeah and you've looked at what
you have and yes machine learning is
still a good fit the next thing to do is
actually prepare your data so making
sure that you have enough data to train
and is your data clean and ready so data
preparation is new if you're used to
traditional programming and it's
important it's going to feel weird if
you're used to spending all day
programming but now you're like editing
images or sorting files but managing
data is really important and to
illustrate that there was a survey by
CrowdFlower
they talked to about Turner data
scientists and they said they spend
fifty to eighty percent of their time
just preparing their data and they also
said it's their least favorite part of
the job so humans being humans they
would not be doing this especially not
so much if it weren't really really
important to the sex to the success of
what they're trying to do and so one of
the reason this is so important is that
your data is going to determine the
accuracy of your model how well this
works you may or may not have heard if
you hear anyone talking about garbage in
garbage out that's what they're talking
about if you feed your algorithm garbage
it's going to learn garbage and it's
going to give you garbage so some things
that can go wrong are finding an
accidental pattern instead of what you
want and so my favorite example of this
is there are people trying to teach the
computer the difference between a husky
and a wolf it's kind it can be hard to
do they're pretty similar looking
animals and they thought they had it
they changed their data they tested it
and it was really really accurate and
telling difference between how
skeena wolf until they started looking
at how it was making those decisions and
it wasn't hadn't learned the difference
through the Husky a wolf it was a snow
detector that almost all of their images
of wolves were in the snow and Huskies
were usually in someone's backyard and
so it had no idea what a wolf was it
just knew what snow was and this was not
at all what they were trying to identify
so the type of thing that if you're not
careful can creep into your data and you
might be creating a system that does not
do what you actually wanted it to
it can also be confused by a bad data so
if your labels are wrong like you just
maybe crowdsource something off the
internet using you know if you're
looking at images oh people label these
google images this way but if they're
not accurate and you're again teaching
it garbage and learning those wrong
labels that other people have given it
so you do is also going to determine
what type of machine learning you do so
there's so many different models and
they're usually what gets talked about
when you talk about machine learning you
know there's this model and it learns in
this way and it does this but which one
you choose is going to be driven by your
data do you have enough enough examples
to support this model do you need a
model that will sort your your data into
different categories or classes like dog
cat wolf or you need something that
assigns it a value like temperature or
money or time or sometimes do you not
even have any labels at all and you just
want to see you know what what's in my
day - how can I sort things that are
similar so all of these things are
determined by your data and this is why
it's such a really important part of
this so when you're preparing your data
set some things to keep in mind having
enough data that it has to be accurate
and it needs to be relevant so you need
to make sure that you're giving the
algorithm useful information to the
problem you're trying to solve
so really extreme example is that if you
want to teach it to identify you know a
cat versus a dog pictures of houses and
your data set probably aren't helpful
unless you also want it to identify this
is not a cat or a dog which is you know
some another decision you have to make
do you care if your system you know is
your system going to get any weird
unexpected data and you're have to
account for that if you know you'll
never get a picture of a house there's
no reason to do that but if someone
could upload one and you don't want them
laughing at your system because you said
it was a cat you might want to include
that as an example of not a cat or not a
dog and so this is where subject matter
experts are going to be helpful if you
have access to anyone who understands
the data and understands the problem
they don't have to be a machine learning
person but if they understand what
you're trying to do and how a human
might make those decisions they can help
drive your data decisions what day D do
you give the algorithm how do you try
and train it and the your data also has
to be complete you can't have missing
information so for example medical
records if a person's age is missing
most algorithms don't know what to do
with not a number or blank entries so
you want to find some way to fix that
whether that's removing any example
that's missing data or if you can find
ways to fill in or guess at what it
should be with like the the mean value
or the median value of that column but
you you need to find some way of
accounting for any data that's missing
any as I mentioned before you also have
to cover any examples you expect to see
so whenever an algorithm gets data that
hasn't been trained on there's not a
good way of predicting what it's going
to do it's probably going to take the
closest thing it's seen and go with that
so if you give it a wolf and spin train
on cat and dog it'll probably say dog
because they're similar but you can't
always guarantee what it's going to do
you want to get something on it's
unexpected and so we talked a little
about the type of data determining one
algorithm you choose so if you have
labeled cow categories like cat dog
true/false red green or blue you're
gonna want to be looking into
classification algorithms if you're
looking for a number value like price
temperature time
you're gonna want things that do
regression so it gives you a continuous
value or maybe you have no labels so
this gets a little more interesting your
it's a clustering you're unsupervised
learning so it's good for it can be good
for data exploration or trying to group
pieces of data that are similar together
but if you ever want to make predictions
on new values you're gonna have to find
or make labels somehow so if you don't
have labels you either need to get them
or just be ok that you're just exploring
your data so we're still not done with
the data because we have it but we need
to make sure we use it appropriately so
whenever you're doing machine learning
you're going to need to split your data
into two to three categories so we
typically call them the test set
validation set and training set so the
training site is the biggest chunk and
it's what you train your algorithm on
and this is the only data the algorithm
ever sees you don't train it on your
validation set and you don't train you
on your test set the validation set is
used to you make you train it on your
training set and make predictions on the
validation set and see how many gets
right and you can use that to compare
different algorithms if you want to see
you know there's five algorithms I think
might work I want to see which one works
better and then once you've picked the
best one you test it again on your test
set and this is your final estimation of
if I put this into production how well
is it going to perform so you can think
of it sort of like when you were in
school the training sets kind of like
homework you have a lot of examples
you're learning what to do the
validation sets maybe a practice exam
you want to see how well your algorithm
might be doing and the test set is that
real exam how much of this information
did you learn so if you put the same
questions or examples in the test and
the homework you're not testing them
it's ability to learn the actual
information you're testing its ability
to memorize a few questions it's already
seen and so you want to make sure you
never do anything to bias your test set
or like tweak something weird because it
gets you better answers in your test set
because it's not going to fold a
production system and then you're going
to have to figure out why when you test
it you get
eight results and as soon as you pushed
it to production it fails so never mess
with your test set so we've talked a lot
about this but what does it actually
look like you for going to code it
because we are programmers so first you
want to import a train test split from
scikit-learn it is an awesome so I can't
learn if you're not familiar with it is
an awesome Python library for machine
learning most of the hard things it does
for you it is glorious and you should
look into it so we want to get some data
you would never actually hard code your
data but I'm giving a presentation and
it's just easier to visualize this way
so X are our examples we have five
values each is a pair of numbers so
maybe a set of coordinates and then why
are your labels so we have two different
categories user belongs and category 0
or category 1 and then if you want to
use this train test split you pass it
your examples you pass it your labels
you tell it how large you want your test
size to be so I want 25% of my data in
my test set and then it gives you your
training data tray next train Y and your
test data test X test Y so before moving
on let's talk a little more about this
example data and just show some examples
of some of the problems I mentioned so
we have 5 examples the first 3 the first
number is larger and they belong in
category 0 and the last two the second
numbers larger belongs in category 1 so
these labels look like categories so
we'd probably use classification if we
were actually using this data but some
problems with this data
there's obviously too few examples a
ballpark number is about maybe about 50
if you don't have at least 50 examples
you need to get more or find something
that's not machine learning we've also
got some missing cases like what do we
want the system to do if the numbers are
equal but also and in addition to that
our goal is unclear
so does a label of 1 mean the second
numbers larger or does it mean that the
numbers are sequential 2 3 8 9
so we don't have enough in the real
world we don't have enough data to
actually train a useful algorithm but
we're gonna go ahead with this anyway
because it's just a toy example and what
does the rest of our code look like so
we have a train test split we split our
data now what so you from scikit-learn
again you want to import your model and
they have a ton of different machine
learning models most things that you'd
want to do you just import some library
from scikit-learn so this in particular
is SVM it stands for a support vector
machine it's a pretty good a
classification algorithm if you know
sort things into groups and if you're
just playing around it's also a pretty
good place to start so if you want to
create your classifier you every
classifier will have some kind of
creation method so this is SVM SVC you
might have some parameters to pass in
but you create an object using that
library that you imported and then to
train it you have that model and
everything in scikit-learn should have a
fit function and you pass it your
examples your labels and that is all
there is to actually training the
algorithm so another part of the reason
I spent so much time talking about the
data is because actually training the
algorithm is this this is really all
there is to it and so to evaluate your
model you can import different metrics
from scikit-learn so here we're looking
at the accuracy score and then to make a
prediction the model and adjusted to fit
also has a predict function so you pass
it some more examples here I'm passing
it our test set and it'll give you a
list of what category it thinks each of
those examples belong to and then if you
want to calculate the calculates the
accuracy you would use accuracy score
pass in what it's actually supposed to
be three labels and all of its
predictions and so this will tell you
what percentage of the of the test set
did it get right so that's you know
that's it we've trained a model we've
evaluated it we have
you see you know what else do we have to
think about so back to the final new
part of the mindset how to decide
whether or not it works there's a lot of
different metrics what to decide you
know how well is this performing and do
I need to make it work better so this is
just a few common ones but for
classification accuracies a huge one
just what percentage of the time am i
right but you also have things like
precision you know of the things I said
are dogs how many are actually dogs and
there's also recall so what percentage
of dogs did I find and actually labeled
dogs and they sound really similar and
so that's also part of getting used to
machine learning is get coming to grips
with like what these mean and their
distinctions and when you would use one
versus the other
so for example in my work we use a lot
of precision because we only accept
things that the classifier is really
confident at it's like yeah I'm pretty
sure this is right and so we're mostly
interested in if I bothered to give a
classification did I get that right
whereas we're not worried about the
total percentage as much as some other
people might be and so if you are
worried about like just the whole
overall you know you know you don't drop
anything we include everything then
you'd be more interested in accuracy
it's especially important in medical
situations so if you are considering for
a disease and you want to make sure you
don't miss a single person who has that
disease they all come up positive then
you have to balance how many people who
don't have the disease also come up
positive and so that's one of the places
where that's really gonna come into play
and so I didn't talk much about
regression or trying to predict a
continuous value but some common methods
are the the r-squared score which is
exactly what Excel would give you if you
put a bunch of data in the until to plot
a line that's the score it gives you
back so if you've ever done that you've
already done machine learning there's
also something called the mean squared
error
so for each prediction you take how far
off it is from the value is supposed to
be square that add that all together and
that'll give you a sense of how well
your algorithm is performing so a recap
of everything they've talked about
because I feel like I went through a lot
and talked a lot about data but if you
find yourself suddenly try needing to
learn machine learning just kind of get
prepared to have a new mindset it is
different from traditional programming
but it is a lot of fun
make sure you determine which that
machine learning is the right solution
for your problem don't let people talk
you into using the new buzzword just
because it sounds cool it might not be
the best solution
you want to clean and prepare your out
your data and then a subcategory of that
is depending on your data choose the
best algorithm to use and then try it
out see what happens if it works great
if it doesn't try something a little
different you know maybe you need more
data or different data or maybe you need
a different algorithm just play with it
and see what happens
and then there are a lot of resources on
machine learning I try to pick some that
were a little more introduction friendly
so like I've enjoyed the practical AI
podcast it's a podcast so it can't get
super technical but can introduce you to
ideas at a higher level scikit-learn the
library has some great documentation not
just on how to use their functions but
also what they're for and how you might
want to use them if you're more
interested in things like neural
networks and deep learning 3 blue one
Brown has an awesome series of videos on
how neural networks work it's very he
tries to be very intuitive I just I love
all of his videos actually should check
them out and then there's a website on
neural networks and deep learning that's
more technical but walks you through
building your own neural network Python
programming net has some stuff on
machine learning and then there's a ton
of Coursera courses one I thought was
particularly interesting was Andrew
Aang's course on structuring machine
learning this one's a little more on how
you would structure the project itself
rather than the technical details
but there's a ton more resources out
there this is just kind of to get you
started I hope that was helpful and I'd
be happy to answer any questions awesome
so I know we have one from slide oh that
Josh picked up we're gonna get that
fixed again but Josh's got a question
from slate Oh for you actually so the
question is communicating estimates or
forecasts is difficult in software
development how do you have that even
more challenging conversation around
machine learning yeah so that is a lot
of fun and actually the way that we
approached it was gave the people who
had trouble you know understanding we
put we actually put together a
presentation on the very basics of
machine learning which is act this is
loosely based on that actually but we we
went into a little bit of detail on like
how the algorithms were using work and
why it might be slow at but it was yeah
it was a lot of Education because if
they once they had more of an idea of
like how it works and why it's different
and why it's not magic they were a
little more receptive to like oh I know
it'll take time because the computer
needs to train it for a while and you
know we have to after that we have to
see if it even works and maybe we have
to clean out our data but it was a lot
of Education questions really so we got
lots of questions awesome um got a
question about in a business if you were
joining a new company that didn't do a
lot of machine learning would you start
off by proclaiming the benefits of
machine learning teaching everybody how
to do it getting all these marquee
projects or would you start off by doing
it kind of on the low key and then
presenting the results like because you
don't know necessarily whether or not
you're gonna make a big impact with your
problem and people might be turned off
on it if it fails or there might be like
a short runway for doing machine
learning so how would you tackle it in
like a big enterprise that is a really
good and complicated question so I've
sort of seen both methods
and seeing mixed results with both so
it's if you can get the support so I
guess your best-case scenario is if
there's no other way to do it it's like
if you're trying to identify images of
something there's no other way to do it
so you have your use case like we have
to use machine learning if you want this
to happen
I have seen people work on things below
the radar and it like never pans out or
like people think it's going to pan out
but because there's only one person kind
of like in their little cave working on
it people aren't in the loop and they
don't know what's happening and so if it
winds up not working it could be act
that could actually be a surprise to
people because you're like oh I'm
working on this thing I'm working on
this thing and then it doesn't work and
everyone thought it was going to
eventually so it can be a really tough
balance but I would definitely recommend
doing everything kind of like in view of
everyone and making it actually a part
of the process and if yeah if you're
know if and if you're in an organization
that's not wild about the time frames
and stuff like we've definitely done
some things that would have been better
with machine learning but because you
could hand code it we did and I still
yeah it is very case-by-case and very
strange but if you would all can I
definitely recommend getting everyone on
board and just like the training is part
of it so we do like agile scrum and we
have so many research spikes it's like
this sprint we're going to see if this
thing works and so that has gone a
pretty far away into getting people to
accept it there's like oh you have a
weirdly large number of research spikes
but they sort of got used to it but yeah
it is complicated and good luck question
over here so I'm a little iffy on the
need to define the validation versus the
test set I'm gonna I'm gonna run
precision accuracy and recall or
confusion matrix in any event why would
I not just compare the algorithm
performance on the test set itself so
so this is there's also the question of
what is the best practice and what can
you get away with because sometimes you
can get away with not having a
validation set but the real purpose of
it is getting any bias out of your
decisions so if you are comparing you
know a bunch of algorithms and you
compare them on your test set and you
pick the best you have picked one based
on its performance on that set so if it
just happens to perform really well on
that set of data and you don't test it
on a separate set of set of data the
fact that you picked the best performing
one can bias how old actually do because
you could be if you're only training if
you're only testing a couple things it's
less of a problem but if you tested and
compared a million examples the
probability that one doesn't actually
work well it just happened to work well
on that set of data goes way up and so
the idea of having a separate test set
is you could catch that if it you know I
picked this because it did well in
validation and it tanks on tests it must
have been something really weird with
why I chose that is that was a reason
why it's much okay you made a question
yet another question on the photo so
David asks how do you decide between
traditional machine learning algorithms
and neural nets so neural networks are
good there's some things that are like
machine or yeah neural networks are
definitely the best at so anything with
images or anything where you need the
algorithm to determine its features and
so I haven't talked about features
explicitly but they're what you decide
to give the network to train on so the
you know pictures of dogs and cats
there's no features there it's just a
picture and it has to learn what to look
for look for ears or nose or color but
if you're giving it you know like you
want to know housing price and you give
it the square footage the number of
rooms those are all features so if you
want the algorithm to learn features
neural networks are great for that if
you have a lot of data
neural networks are great for that but
they do require a lot of data to train
and so if you don't have as much data
you would probably have better results
sticking with traditional machine
learning or if you don't want to sit
through the time it takes to train a
neural network because they are slower
to Train traditional methods are usually
faster and a lot of them but not all of
them are more explainable so if it's
important that you can explain to
someone why it made a decision you know
one that works are a terrible idea
regarding deep learning specifically
what would be your approach if I just
wanted to become comfortable with
setting up neural nets and do you have
an opinion on like pi torch versus
tensor flow versus whatever else is out
there on that so my personal favorite is
Kerris which definitely wraps tensor
flow and it might wrap it's kind of like
a wrapper for a couple other backends
but the main reason I like it is because
usually what I do if I'm working with
images you can actually download
straight through Karis a trained model
that has already like like there's
Google's model that they put in the
image net competition you can download
that and then you can do what's called
transfer learning you pull off their
labels because I don't care if it's a
cat or a dog I put on the labels that I
want and you don't need nearly as much
of data or as much time you just train
that end layer a little bit so that's
one of the main reasons I like Karis is
just really easy to work with will have
its preference like if you are reading
about something and you like the way it
works or you know the way they handle
code
it's definitely never a bad thing to
learn any of them and once you learn one
the others are gonna be a lot easier
was there another part of your question
because I just run with the cares part
there's a tinge of way part
okay can you repeat that part for the
recording so I think the summary is if
you if you don't have your own dataset
and you just want to learn what is the
best way to kind of get started so
catalyst is pretty good for this that
they have datasets that you can use and
have kind of organized competitions
there's I really wish I remembered the
name but there is another like dataset
repository where you can upload a data
set for anyone to play around with so
yeah if you you can find datasets on the
internet or through kaggle to kind of
like give you a premade goal to try and
for neural networks I like I for a
general understanding I like three blue
one Browns video and then there's a
couple courses like neural Nets and deep
learning and a couple in Coursera that
will walk you through how to build your
own network and so a lot of them start
with like building it from like the
individual neuron but it's it's good
background and by the end you'll have
something you can use so I like a lot of
stuff like that oh yes so um within the
context of small datasets in traditional
machine learning um getting started what
metric are you looking for and like in
an ideal like project based setting like
um are you looking to chase metrics
based on confidence like do you get
better results that way rather than
having to make a definitive choice like
at what point do these small data sets
Express better performance in what
environment say where you're willing to
drop off and give no answer versus give
an answer and you're now dealing with
like outliers and things okay so let me
make sure I understand the question for
answer it so you are asking about the
differences between so with traditional
machine learning in small data sets
differences between when you force it to
always give an answer versus when you
can say I don't I'm not confident enough
I'm not giving it and the question was
like
just general differences or okay and so
and then the question was what are the
trade-offs on that so the advantage to
being able to say I don't know comes
when you are not necessarily when you're
more penalized for giving an answer and
being wrong than for not giving an
answer so if you have a backup system so
for example if you're like we're if
you're automating data entry and you
have some humans back to back you up and
you're just trying to make their job go
faster by taking the bulk of it you can
say I don't know give it to the human
you've done nothing wrong if you have no
backup system and you absolutely have to
make a decision so like in a
self-driving car I don't know is
probably never an acceptable answer it's
not a small data set but the same idea
kind of applies like if you have a
mission-critical decision and you have
to make a decision then the being able
to say I don't know isn't really an
option one workaround could be if you
don't know to kind of try something else
to get a decision like oh my network
isn't confident but I can turn on a
couple extra sensors or I can try
something different if that's the
possibility that's something you could
do but yeah a lot of it comes down to
like is I don't know an acceptable
answer because there are a lot of
advantages that come if you don't have
to give an answer then you can be a lot
more accurate because if you're not sure
you just won't say anything I got time
for like two more questions that's just
actually gonna make a comment about the
question on how to introduce machine
learning to your company one of our
executives is trying to do that in our
company and he passed around a podcast
called deep mind was really interesting
podcast where they're interviewing this
foundation or company organization
really in London that started this and
then Google ended up buying them but
it's just some jaw-dropping inferences
that have been developed by machine
learning that gets people excited about
it and it's
catching on in our company it's kind of
a neat way to introduce it
[Music]